dr raynard had lost everything his job
the respect of his peers and if everyone
else was right perhaps even his mind it
was 11 pm when he staggered to the edge
of okanagan lake in british columbia
eyes and judgment clouded with booze
this lake could have been what made his
career as a researcher for the scp
foundation but now that bright future
was slipping through his fingers like
the dry silt beneath his feet he looked
hatefully across the endless dark
surface of the water and loudly cursed
stupid empty place just hours ago he'd
been stripped of his ranks and released
from his position at the foundation for
wasting the organization's time and
resources on frivolous personal projects
frivolous you thought what a terrible
joke just because the higher-ups refused
to acknowledge what was going out here
didn't mean it wasn't there moonlight
shimmered off the water's surface wait
was that moonlight or was there
something lurking underneath the water
to truly answer this question if any
answer is possible at all we need to go
back to the beginning and ask ourselves
a different question how does the scp
foundation actually find most of the
anomalies it catalogs and contains it is
a simple question with a multifaceted
answer depending on the anomaly in
question for the most part the
foundation has a network of field agents
embedded in pretty much every
institution across the globe including
rival groups of interest like the global
occult coalition and the serpent's hand
if they so much as sniff the strange and
unusual they alert the nearest site
director and the necessary personnel are
dispatched to the scene there's also the
foundation web crawlers which are a form
of specialized software constantly
patrolling the web for anomalous
activity that the foundation wants to
know about and one of the rarer but
still incredibly important methods of
finding scps involve looking into myths
and local legends sure it may seem like
a good way to waste time and resources
but the crossover between recorded scps
and folklore is surprisingly common take
scp-1000 the formerly hyper-intelligent
apes that were nearly the dominant
species on earth until humans and a
certain capricious forest god pulled a
dirty trick on them they're better known
to most civilians as the legendary
bigfoot or sasquatch perhaps the most
famous cryptid of all time or
scp-1337 the hitchhiker an anomalous
spectral entity that manifests in the
cars of those who don't pick her up and
performs horrific acts of violence
against them she's eerily similar to
legends you can find not only all over
the u.s but the entire world of ghostly
hitchhikers intruding into the cars of
unwary travelers and scaring them half
to death or worse if you're unlucky
another case where myths and legends
pointed the scp foundation in exactly
the right direction and of course
there's scp-136
the terrifying naked doll this was an
almost featureless children's doll found
inside an abandoned house but prolonged
time in its presence can make you the
victim of a warped apparition that'll
drive you half mad with fear it's got
such a detrimental psychological effect
on people that the foundation has been
controversially using it as a torture
method during enhanced interrogation
sessions with captured members of rival
groups of interest and how did they find
it the foundation keeps track of
neighborhood rumors about haunted houses
with supposedly supernatural inhabitants
clearly when it looks like it might
actually get results no myth or local
legend is too big or too small to
warrant an investigation from the scp
foundation it was with this mindset that
a younger happier and less drunk dr b
renard set off with his team to okanagan
lake in search of what locals had
referred to as the legendary ogopogo
we've all heard of the loch ness monster
the lake monster from scotland that's
been turning heads for the better part
of a century and may be related to two
other similar scps namely
scp-3934 and scp-5533
but ocopogo is canada's answer to good
old nessie while the loch ness monster
resembles a pleosure the ocopogo is much
more serpentine with a long coiling body
covered in green scales its long tail is
said to be able to create fierce storms
along the surface of the water with its
vicious whips killing scores of
unfortunate adventurers who dared stray
too close the name ogopogo is also a
palindrome meaning it reads the same
forwards as it does backwards and is
believed to have originated in the
novelty song from the year 1924
however it's likely that the actual
beast this somewhat goofy name was given
to is a much older fiercer entity and
for the sake of his reputation as a
researcher as he took a plane to the
okanogan valley dr renard very much
hoped this was the case of course he'd
explored the legends heavily so much so
that he was sure there had to be
something to this whole thing the
schwepmeck and celix peoples the lake
dwelling monster was known as naitaka
which has been loosely translated into
the sacred creature of the water the
water god and most menacing of all the
water demon the beast was often
described in oral traditions as being a
malicious supernatural entity with great
power and ill intent towards those
trespassing on its territory legend has
it that anyone who crosses okanagan lake
the supposed domain of the ogapogo needs
to make a sacrifice to the monster in
order to ensure safe passage those who
refuse to give the sacrifice the beast
demanded would pay a heavy toll being
devoured or dragged down to a watery
grave never to be seen again and this
monster isn't just some old folk tale
either contemporary sightings have dated
back to 1873 with both settlers and
first nations people alike spotting the
sinister ogopogo in the intervening
years dr renard had poured through the
files on hundreds of sightings there
were a number of incidents in the 1980s
so much so that the environmentalist
group greenpeace moved to have the
creature classified as a protected
species naturally official sources
decided against the idea claiming that
none of the sightings were of substance
in 1992 a vast shape filmed under the
murky water in okanagan lake was
suggested to be the legendary beast
however the fbi stepped in to deny the
validity of this case stating that the
beast was much more likely to be debris
falling off a local tree disappointing
lovers of the strange and unusual
everywhere in 2011 nearly 20 years later
there was more video footage of a
sighting showing large dark shapes
moving underneath the surface of the
okanogan lake however this claim was
once again dismissed by all outside
parties claiming the shape of the beast
underneath the water was more likely to
be a pair of logs bummer 2018 was an
exciting year for the ogopogo with three
different sightings of the creature
being reported at different times
throughout the year witnesses describe
the creature as being a giant snake
around 50 feet long which is consistent
with a lot of the historical
descriptions of the beast as well as
being over twice as long as the
reticulated python
the non-anomalous longest snake in the
world so naturally authority figures
once again shot down the validity of any
claims that the creature was actually
real and out there dr renard found this
almost funny they didn't even need to
suppress knowledge of this creature if
it really was out there mainstream
sources seem to be doing their job for
them and keeping the creature covered up
he once determined though that he would
be the one to prove to his superiors
that this creature was indeed real and
lurking in okanagan lake he organized a
number of varied investigative missions
from actively trawling the lake itself
to conducting interviews with first-hand
witnesses as well as those who claim to
see no merit in their evidence and
testimony dr renard noticed a strange
phenomenon the people who'd seen it
firsthand were as certain that it was
real as the doubters were that it was
fake even for typical skeptics the
non-believers seem shockingly resolute
that there was really nothing down there
and the alleged photos and videos were
100 bogus early diagnostic tests into
the lake directly overseen by dr renard
seemed to point to a creature clearly
being down there he found the direct
testimony both compelling and consistent
with what he and his team were catching
glimpses of so why were people so
adamant that nothing was down there it
was almost like the ogopogo really was
as mythical as the first nations legend
said and it was casting a spell on all
the non-believers that's when it hit dr
renard like a perfect bolt of lightning
they weren't just looking at a
particularly large sea snake with
unnatural longevity here they were
looking at a sea serpent with cognito
hazardous powers it was a beast with a
perfect defense mechanism only those who
sought up close would actually believe
that the creature was real anyone who
found out about it via secondary sources
would experience an extreme state of
incredulity nobody except those who saw
it directly would ever believe that it
existed and thus even the most
intelligent prey would lower their
defenses around its domain an elegant
and dangerous anomalous hunter dr renard
had found himself a worthy opponent and
one that would help him make his mark at
the foundation he drew up the file and
gave it the designation
scp-1933 before sending it back to his
supervisors they wrote back saying that
they didn't feel as though there was
enough of a basis and evidence to deem
this entry worthy of inclusion if dr
renard wanted to have his so-called
ogopogo dignified with entry into the
scp foundation archives he needed to
back it up properly this presented a
problem to dr renard how could he
provide documentation and evidence for a
creature that had the defining anomalous
power of making all of its own
documentation and evidence seem phony he
was caught between a rock and a hard
place with only one solution create the
most undeniably high quality evidence of
the creature that the world had ever
seen not long after that his superiors
at the scp foundation would receive a
video file from dr renard according to
the notes on his report he set up a
track using an elk carcass to lure the
creature out of the water and capture hd
video of its feeding when the senior
researchers gathered around to watch the
video they were astounded an animatronic
a cheap rubber suit around a somewhat
janky robot like something you'd see at
a theme park how much had dr renard
spent on this absurd farce did he think
it was funny despite dr renard's
protests he was reprimanded severely for
this waste of foundation resources the
object class on his 1933 file was
switched to explained meaning a rational
non-anomalous explanation for the
observed phenomenon had been found
discrediting it and the 1933 slot was
instead filled with a strange fat man
dressed as santa claus whose bodily
fluids are all irish cream the ultimate
humiliation dr renard was left with
nothing and we join him once again where
we started with dr renard standing on
the ledge of okanagan lake staring
hatefully into the water as something
seemed to move underneath if dr renard
screamed that night there was nobody
there to hear it his remains were
dredged out of the lake the next day his
official cause of death was listed as
drowning after an unfortunate boating
accident though the boat in question was
never found reports that his corpse was
found half eaten have mostly been
dismissed as rumors after all there is
no such thing as the ogopogo now go
check out
scp-1861 the crew of the hms
wintershimer and the horror of body
stealing rain
scp-3300 for more ominous aquatic
anomalies